well it's been an
exciting night so far but we're not done
yet there are still three big awards to
come
if you win you'll go home with a spirit
award and if you're stephen young and
you win
you get one night with melissa
that's right stephen young if you win
you get one night with melissa no
strings attached
here's how it's gonna go i'll give you
one night with melissa
just you and me in my queen size bed
all you have to bring is the cowboy hat
that you wore in the photos in your gq
spread
one night with melissa
i might call you glenn from the walking
dead i hope your guy
is still alive i'm only up to season six
i don't really care if your farm is bad
i'll still live with you
in arkansas my grandma
can't sleep on the floor she's also part
of the deal
i'm in good shape cause i work in tb so
i have to keep my body tight
now i like your people in movies who can
put on 20 pounds and pretend it's for a
character
one night with melissa van gaal the
spirit award says it's okay
oh please god let stephen young win
but in all seriousness we're not playing
favorites here tonight
all right there's a very good chance
stephen young might not win
in which case he would only get two
nights with melissa
two nights is better than one and if you
wanna bring rizz ahmed that's also
totally cool
you